The Truth About Medieval Chastity Belts
The lasting images of what most of us perceive
to be the “medieval times” includes heroic
knights, stampeding horses, court jesters,
giant turkey legs, ruling kings, and pure
maidens wearing chastity belts.
But the fact is that, besides the more obvious
of those that aren’t accurate, most scholars
believe that the chastity belt didn’t actually
exist during medieval times, but rather is
a product of 18th and 19th century obsession
with masturbation as a societal ill and safeguarding
women in the workplace.
According to the popular myth, chastity belts
were locked metal or leather belts that young
maidens wore to keep themselves “pure.”
The myths usually date the belts to the Crusades
(an approximately two hundred year period
between the 11th and 13th centuries) when
knights would be gone for years, raping and
pillaging in the name of God, and their wives
would be left at home, perhaps lonely and
looking for companionship or at the least
vulnerable to unscrupulous men.
So to guard against this, the story goes that
the knights would make their wives wear chastity
belts as a pledge of fidelity and for protection.
Except these stories weren’t true and, in
fact, knights and maidens had likely never
even heard the term “chastity belt.”
The adjective “chaste” first appeared
around the 12th century with an original meaning
of, “virtuous, pure from unlawful sexual
intercourse” (“unlawful sexual intercourse”
as defined by the Church).
The first time “chaste” appeared as a
noun was in the 14th century with the definition
of “virgin person.”
The first known depiction of a chastity belt,
or “female chastity device,” only dates
back 600 years to Konrad Kyeser’s 1405 book
on military technology, Bellifortis.
In the book, Kyeser writes about and draws
battering rams, crossbows, instruments of
torture, mentions how to castrate a man, and,
though not particularly related to war directly
(merely soldier’s pastimes), describes a
female chastity device.
The “female chastity device” drawn by
Kyeser is accompanied by this text (translated):
These are hard iron breeches of Florentine
women which are closed at the front.
He goes on to state in an equally ironic tone,
Padlocks unto the four-legged creatures, breeches
unto the women of Florence, A joke binds this
lovely series together, I recommend them to
the noble and obedient youth.
Given the lack of any verifiable artifacts
from this era (or indeed for a couple centuries
more), and the tongue and cheek manner such
devices are mentioned here, it is thought
by most historians that they either weren’t
widely used or he simply made them up and
was insinuating that Florentine women were
not generally open to soldier’s advances.
That said, several poems of this era do refer
to chastity belts, though as simple strips
of cloth that covered the female’s privates.
They are also generally mentioned as more
of a symbolic gesture.
Essentially, it was a promise ring…. but
a bit further south.
Paintings and drawings from 15th and 16th
centuries depict women wearing metal chastity
belts (even, padlocks on their tongues), but
these appear in stories as fictional narrative
elements.
As in, a story where a jealous husband forces
his wife to wear a lock and key belt to prevent
her from running off with a rival of his.
Certainly no one would have worn a padlock
on their tongue, and wearing such metal devices
directly against the skin and genitals for
lengthy periods of time was a sure-fire way
to get abrasive wounds and infection, which
particularly back then could be lethal.
The lack of surviving artifacts or direct
documentation of anyone actually wearing these
once again has historians skeptical that anyone
did at this point in history, but at the least
with the increasing number of mentions in
fiction, it’s possible that some individuals
really did wear them.
So when did the first, verifiable chastity
belt come about?
You might have heard that the first was from
1388, owned by Francesco di Carrara II, the
last sovereign lord of Padua (the oldest city
in northern Italy).
The belt was supposedly designed by him presumably
for his wife.
The belt is still on display at the Doges
Palace in Venice, but many historians doubt
its legitimacy.
In fact, several prominent museums, including
the world-renown British Museum, have either
removed or changed the dates listed on their
collection of similar chastity belts due to
concerns that they weren’t from the 14th,
15th, or 16th centuries.
For instance, one of the chastity belts housed
at the Musée de Cluny (National Museum of
the Middle Ages) in Paris, long thought to
belong to Catherine de Medici, was erroneously
labeled as from the 15th century.
In the 1990s, they tested the metal and, as
it turns out, it dates only back to the early
19th century.
This perhaps shouldn’t be a surprise as
the Victorian era was when chastity belts
had their heyday.
To get around the metal on skin problem, these
chastity belts typically included some sort
of padding like leather or cloth, which was
changed frequently.
These belts were typically used for two reasons
– to prevent masturbation, and to protect
women in the workplace.
For much of the 19th and even into the 20th
century, masturbation (by both men and women)
was considered a societal ill.
An 1853 book entitled “The Silent Friend”
gives the example of “L.D.” and what happened
to him due to his constant masturbation,
He less resembled a living creature than a
corpse, lying upon straw, meager, pale, and
filthy, casting forth an infectious stench,
almost incapable of motion, a watery palish
blood issuing from the nose, the tongue frightfully
swelling, and saliva constantly frothing from
his mouth…the disorder of the mind was equal
to the body.
A few decades later in a medical text, it
was said you should,
Teach your boy that when he handles or excites
the sexual organs, all parts of the body suffer.
This is why it is called “self-abuse.”
The sin is terrible, and is, in fact, worse
than lying or stealing.
For, although these are wicked and will ruin
the soul, self-abuse will ruin both soul and
body.
This loathsome habit lays the foundation for
consumption, paralysis, and heart disease.
It makes many boys lose their minds; others,
when grown, commit suicide.
A few centuries earlier, one of the many problems
Martin Luther had with the Catholic Church
was the idea that the clergy should be celibate,
which he felt encouraged the “sinful”
act of masturbation.
As he stated, “Nature never lets up…
We are all driven to the secret sin.
To say it crudely but honestly, if it doesn’t
go into a woman, it goes into your shirt.”
Fast-forward back to the 19th century and,
according to the “Cultural Encyclopedia
of the Body,” in some circles, girls were
not allowed to even ride bikes or horses for
fear that this simulated masturbation.
Special boys’ pants were designed to prevent
them from touching their genitals through
the pockets.
To that extreme end, chastity belts were forced
upon some young women during the Victorian
era to prevent masturbation.
Also during this time, some women found wearing
chastity belts quite handy outside of any
temptation.
With the Industrial age commencing in America
and Europe, more women found themselves in
factories and the workplace.
At times, these were dangerous places for
women, particularly with the rampant drunkenness
often found by workers in the factories of
this era.
Locked metal chastity belts worn away from
the home provided a great deal of protection.
Today, chastity belts have made a resurgence
for use in sexual role-playing.
We will leave it at that, but next time, someone
talks about a fair maiden from medieval times
and her chastity belt, you can let them know
that the evidence that chastity belts were
used during the medieval times is scant, being
more a product of the much more recent Victorian
era.